un sans logis cherche un endroit pour se
réchauffer en 30 minutes deux hommes
viennent trouvé refuge ici pourtant on
n'est pas à montréal mais à 240 km au
nord à mont-laurier labrie a été ajouté
l'hiver dernier un symbole du problème
qui frappe désormais les régions même
éloigné ça répondait au besoin qu'on
avait que des gens qui couchait dans les
tentes de toile dans la rue puis on
s'est dit bonjour à un moment donné
c'est faut leur faire une place pour que
puisse se réchauffer
plusieurs sont en effet forcé de camper
au bord de la 117 on retrouve gilles qui
dort dans le bois près de mont-laurier
c'est ça la benauge
il arrive d'abitibi et puis on
finit tous pour tous tous pour ci
dessous
son père c'est la pénurie de logements
y'a pas de logement les gens savent en
salle à vue parce que la pénurie de
logements est encore plus grave ici qu'à
montréal le taux d'inoccupation est de
3,2 pour cent dans la métropole mais il
n'est que de 1,7 pour cent à mont
laurier avec la pandémie l'engouement
pour les régions a provoqué une hausse
de 3% de la population
ça crée un arabe ça crée un marché
encore plus parce que les joyaux le beau
jeu d'augmenter encore plus les loyers
d'exiger encore plus avec cet exode aux
devils arena les régions les plus
vulnérables et coop au coeur du petit
centre ville je rencontre un autre sans
abri comme on le voit à montréal
le jeune homme dort au fond d'un parc
pour assister à ce matin il cherche de
la métamphétamine avec la pandémie
l'accès aux drogues illégales est aussi
encore plus compliqué dans des endroits
comme on leur y est on est un
consommateur régulier ça devient comme
compliquée des spatules procurer de la
drogue ou que le prix augmente ça
complique avis a propulsé à consommer d
[Musique]
des substances plus dangereuse plus
coupés et quand de plus grand impact sur
la santé mentale
la maison lise beauchamp permettent à
des dizaines de personnes comme steve de
sortir de la rue
[Musique]
après 15 ans d'itinérance il a
maintenant un petit logement supervisé
par la maison lise beauchamp mais
l'organisme aimerait avoir plus d'être
des médecins à l'hôpital de mont laurier
par des psychiatres et des
infirmières spécialisés en psychiatrie
n'est pas monsieur à une fois moins 25
degrés
est héberge la fin sur musculation la
pandémie a accentué la crise du logement
est aggravé la pénurie de personnel dans
le réseau de la santé ce qui fait que
les succès comme celui de steve risque
d'être un peu plus rare à l'avenir ici
david gêne-t-il et radio-canada mont
laurier